[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
qui sera consacré aux rapports entre la
religion la société l'état question
d'actualité avec la publication du
rapport sauvé sur les pédophiles au sein
de l'église question aussi de faux
puisque quelle est la place de la
religion dans une société laïque et
sécularisée pour en parler florence
mercadé choqué bonjour jean lacasse au
barreau de versailles et spécialiste
notamment du droit du travail de la
place de la religion dans le droit du
travail
monseigneur bruno valentin bonjour
bonjour matrice vous êtes évêque
coadjuteur de verser avec auxiliaires
maman de versailles il vous est aussi
l'auteur de na li qui s'appelle rebâtir
ou laisser tomber l'église au coeur
c'était aux éditions emmanuel et c'est
peut-être la question que se posent
beaucoup de catholiques est ce qu'il
faut rebâtir ou laisser tomber on va
vous parler notamment après la
publication du rapport sauvé vincent
couronne bonjour bonjour patrice vous
êtes en droit vous êtes le fondateur le
confondateur des surligneurs et les
surligneurs justement publie un livre
auquel a participé raphaël mata deviner
au kivu maître de conférences à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en jean patrice ce livre voilà vous
faites du lait gagne ce king à ce qu'on
appelle le légal trekking c'est à dire
vous regardez les propositions des
hommes et des femmes politiques et s qui
sont compatibles ou poids ou pas avec
avec notre droit et voilà le premier
livre qui paraît alors pour vous
retrouver sur vos sites mais ce premier
livre paraît et il consacré justement au
rapport de la religion de la laïcité et
de la politique
alors on va peut-être commencer
immédiatement puisque c'est là qu elle
était avec le rapport le rapport sauvé
sur les crimes pédophiles au sein de
l'église
[Musique]
selon selon ce rapport
depuis
1950 entre 210 mille ha grâce à des
pensions prend des agressions par des
prêtres ou bardelli qui travaillent dans
les églises ou trois cent mille ans font
vote était agressé sexuellement
six pour cent des victimes dans
l'ensemble de la de la population ont
été victimes d'agressions c'était à 5
millions et demi
il ya un un de vos collègues un évêque
qui s'appelle monseigneur le borgne qui
dit comment at on pu ne pas voir ça mais
c'est vrai que là c'est la première
question qu'on s'est tous posé en
découvrant ce chiffre parce que faut
bien comprendre que
la commission sauvé après deux ans et
demi d'appel à témoignage après un
travail
incroyable de d'analysé archives avaient
identifié 3000 personnes
une enquête épidémiologique en
population générale sur un échantillon
de 28 mille personnes dont d'une rigueur
scientifique incontestable abouti à ce
chiffre en mode de sondage finalement de
216 me lui donc on a été saisie par cet
écart allant mais comment comment on
peut connaître le 3000 personnes alors
que la réalité était de 116 me c'est
vrai qu'on a été saisie par l'ampleur de
ce qui nous a été décrit et
donc yahiaoui set mais c'est pas une
découverte quand même parce que c'est
l'église qui est elle à l'origine de ce
rapport malheureusement le drame de la
pédocriminalité dans l'église n'est pas
une découverte c'est bien pour ça que
les évêques ont demandé cette commission
et l'ont financé parce qu'il savait
effectivement qu'il existait un problème
mais on en soupçonner ni l'ampleur ni je
dirais la gravité on a près sûr que oui
c'est saclay l'église échos frotter à
une question qu'elle connaissait mais
dos peut-être ne savait pas comment
sortir elle même en fait c'est ça je
crois qu'il faut prendre avec humilité
et clarté les conclusions du rapport
sauvé qui dit clairement que l'église
elle a fait trop peu trop tard et de
manière beaucoup trop disparates et des
diocèses qui sont vraiment mobilisés
d'autres beaucoup moins donc oui c'est
clair qu' il est temps de changer de
braquet en matière de lutte contre la
pédocriminalité dans l'église d'abord et
probablement aussi dans la société tout
entière c'est le travail désormais de la
commission du juge durant que d'analyser
la masse du phénomène
et 90% des victimes c'est à dire le
problème de l'inceste le problème de la
sesc pour le de la pédophilie c'est vrai
que si on regarde alors un peu plus
historiquement le le la relation que la
société peut avoir par rapport à ces
crimes a beaucoup évolué et je me suis
alors dans l'après 68 ont parlé
d'éducation sexuelle des enfants
s'étaient pas tabou et c'est vrai pour
les analyses que j'ai trouvé très
intéressante maintenant le rapport sauvé
c'est à dire que il montre bien que pour
expliquer ces phénomènes il ya un socle
commun à toute la société une volonté
commune de ne pas voir de ne pas savoir
et des facteurs propres à l'église et
ils identifient bien l'articulation des
deux c'est vraiment un travail ou
interdisciplinaire croisant des des
juristes des magistrats des psychiatres
des anthropologues d'une dune d'une
richesse exceptionnelle sera pour sauver
est-ce que vous avez été frappé beaucoup
d'autre part la publication de ce
rapport
sonne c'est c'est ce que je trouve
intéressant dans la démarche c'est le
fait que ce soit à l'initiative de
l'église en fait que ce rapport était
dit était fait et ce qui a peut-être
permis un accès à des archives et c est
peut-être qu'on peut dire que
effectivement je suis d'accord avec ce
qui vient d'être dit sur la richesse du
rapport qui est peut-être même unique
dans les différentes enquêtes et des
différentes démarches qui ont été
qui ont été effectués dans le monde sur
ce sur ce sujet là donc le travail en
france qui a été fait sur le sujet va
probablement apporter aussi une nouvelle
manière
de lutter contre la pédocriminalité au
sein de l'église où d'autres confessions
et c'est ptet c'est une très bonne chose
oui
je suis sur la même longueur d'onde que
vincent effectivement ce le fait que
l'église est décidée elle même de se
lancer dans cette course eux ont ce
travail d'audit interne j'ai envie de
renvoyer soit bien de ceux de ce
contrôle interne et est à souligner et
comme me le disait monsieur monseigneur
l'évêque je pense également que à côté
de l'église il va falloir qu'on se met
aussi à regarder ce qui s'est passé dans
d'autres systèmes c'est à dire par
exemple les colonies de vacances je
pense aussi à ceux à ce lieu où les
enfants subissent aussi des traitements
c'est vrai que si on veut très clair il
a en gros la plus belle ville ils vont
garder les lieux où il ya des enfants
facettes c'est ce que je dis mais c'est
vrai effacés c'est les collègues des
vacances et laissez des écoles c'est un
signe d'amour est il n'y a pas que
l'église y apparaît non il ya toujours
pas cliquer et c'est vrai il va un
article de la frise of chantal delsol
dans le dans le figaro qui disait et
c'est probablement vrai que pendant
longtemps alors l'époque est en train de
changer mais on a toujours plus protéger
les institutions l'église mais la
famille aussi plutôt que les individus
et on est peut-être dans une dans une
période de la société où les choses
évoluent et les led le jugement comme ça
et le la vision des victimes aussi
évolué oui il ya un changement en
perspective
perfect tic etc et salutaire qui est
salutaire parce que on ne peut pas
sacrifier des vies au bassin qu'il y ait
des personnes à l'intérêt des
institutions aujourd'hui à une oreille
je dirais modernes ces deux
une vision des choses qui étaient
insupportables et heureusement
n'ont pas te dire que maintenant on est
plus dans le dans l'ère des petits
arrangements je crois qu'il ya eu toute
une période post soixante huitarde où la
place de l'enfant la sexualité était un
peu particulier un peu particulière est
aujourd'hui très répréhensibles et donc
au fil du temps quand on avance on voit
bien qu'on rentre effectivement dans un
système d'individualisation et
auparavant c'est des petits arrangements
que ce soit dans la famille que ce soit
dans l'église que ce soit dans
différentes institutions où on
s'arrangeait pour étouffer la faire et
que je vais faire cesser les faibles ou
non c'est plus comme ça et au sein des
familles aussi au sein des familles des
amis je reviens justement chantal delsol
dans cet argus figaro et je parle aux
juristes elle dit au fond le l'intégrité
de l'enfant qui la personne la plus
fragile et de droit naturel donc il faut
le protéger donc c'est toujours un crime
dans le temps et dans l'espace que de le
salir qu'est ce que vous en caisse qu'en
pensent les juristes de ce droit naturel
de l'enfant enfin la protection de
l'enfant en tout cas
disons que sans aller jusqu'à dire que
c'est un droit naturel on reconnaît bien
là je pense que chantal delsol avec pas
mal de positions qu'elle a pu prendre
sur le sur le sujet des libertés et des
libertés fondamentales et je suis pas
étonné qu'elle ne parle ici de droit
naturel pour les enfants pour la
protection des enfants ce que on entend
ici par droit naturel je pense que c'est
de considérer que dans
comment dire que l'humanité aujourd'hui
ne
considère vraiment l'enfant comme ayant
un intérêt supérieur et qu'il faut
absolument protéger et que cet intérêt
il a
alors parce qu'il n'est et être que s'il
devient et qu'il est un être humain dès
là dès la naissance chantal delsol
considère que du coup comme c'est
naturel c'est dire qu'il a ce droit là
dès avant même sa naissance mais bon ça
c'est des différences de vue mais je
pense que ce qu'elle dit ici et sur
lequel on peut être on est assez
d'accord c'est que healy a véritablement
un une importance aujourd'hui primordial
dans la place de l'enfant qui est
extrêmement protégé aujourd'hui dans
notre société et c'est pas plus mal
après je sais pas ce que c'est sauf que
c'est pas choquant du tout dès lors que
l'enfant n'a pas de défense a une
admiration pour les adultes est
théoriquement doit être protégé par les
adultes et il est encore en construction
et donc un enfant peut pas déjà un signe
subi ce qu'il subit peut imaginer que
c'est de sa faute peut imaginer que
l'adulte voilà un pouvoir sur lui et qui
ne peut pas dénoncer et il ya très peu
d'enfants qui subissent ce genre de
2,2 hors équine qui ne disent rien qui
couvrent l'adulte fait je dirais pas
faim je ne rentrerai pas dans le débat
du droit naturel en tout cas pas pas
maintenant qu'ils peuvent les
philosophies si je comprends même si je
comprends l'idée par contre là où je
suis d'accord c'est que l'enfant est une
personne vulnérable et à ce titre là
l'enfant mérite d'être protégé peut-être
un peu plus en tout cas de ce qu'on
fasse que la législation fasse un peu
plus pour protéger l'enfant c'est à ce
titre de personne vulnérable cela étant
il ya une législation sur les atteintes
aux personnes vulnérables du nord de
cinq ans et c'est vrai qu'on voit de
plus en plus notre droit évoluer dans un
sens ou l'obligation de protéger
l'enfant d'un compte plus seulement aux
parents mais de plus en plus à tout un
tas de l'autorité publique morales
privées etc
par exemple une un chef d'établissement
dans une école qui aurait conçu
connaissances ou de rumeurs que ce soit
sur des maltraitances dont d'urgence
porter son enfant à l'obligation d'agir
il ya toute une jurisprudence de la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme là
dessus qu'ils obligent vraiment l'état à
agir pour protéger les enfants
voilà des d'agissements d'autres
d'autres adultes ou même d'autres
enfants alors justement il ya une sur
deux pôles et demi qui est qui est née
sur le secret de la confession
le président de des évêques de france a
semblé dire que vol pour les catholiques
le secret de la confession été plus fort
que la loi c'est vrai que la loi réprime
quelqu'un qui a connaissance de faits
d'atteintes à des enfants d'antoine
sexuelle des enfants et qui ne les
dénoncent pas et le ministre de
l'intérieur a alors à plus ou moins
qu'on votait en tout cas va voir
le président de l'épiscopat français en
disant en rappelant lui que la loi est
plus forte que la religion
alors peut-être europe au prince
explique des histoires sur ce secret de
la confession est ce que pour un pour un
catholique pratiquant le secret de la
confession est plus fort que la loi
alors en fait il s'agit clairement d'une
formule un peu malheureuse de ligue 2
moulins beaufort il ans il a reconnu
sans difficulté parce que la question
fondamentalement ne se pose pas telle
quelle dans la mesure où aujourd'hui en
france un prêtre qui confesse il le fait
dans le cadre de la loi qui reconnaît
aux prêtres comme à tant d'autres
professions les avocats les médecins un
secret professionnel et un secret
professionnel il faut le rappeler qui
n'est pas d'abord un droit du
professionnel à se taire mais un devoir
un devoir donc aux yeux de la loi
française c'est l'article 226 du code
pénal un prêt qui trahi le secret de
confession il est passible de quinze
mille euros d'amendé clairement prison à
sens mais oui rien rien du
prêtre sait mais comme tous les autres
c'est pas spécifique au pana est le
secret professionnel voilà
là pourquoi d'armes aux nazis alors la
loi c'est pour ça qu'ils voulaient que
oui il ya eu une phrase malheureuse qui
ensuite et bepa mais pourquoi parce
qu'en fait si on si on va au plan
philosophique en fait d'où ça vient
cette question ça vient de
l'articulation entre la loi et
le rôle de la conscience en quelque
sorte
de là encore je pense qu a pas matière à
polémique dans la mesure où c'est une
articulation d'abord qui elle aussi est
inscrite dans le droit et surtout sur
laquelle on est tous d'accord je crois
que chacun est d'accord pour dire que le
jour où un nelson mandela ou à charles
de gaulle a fait le choix de la
conscience il a sauvé même l'honneur de
son pays donc le fait qu' on ne puisse
pas dire de manière tout à fait
lapidaire il n'y a rien au dessus de la
loi un point c'est tout je crois qu'en
fait si on n'accepte pas faire des
polémiques comme on aime bien les faire
en france on est assez vite tous
d'accord n'était d'ailleurs françois
mitterrand lui-même président de la
république parler de la force injuste de
la loi ce qui n'est pas
régulé c'est vrai que je voulais moi je
peux pas utiliser ma conscience pour
décider que je paie pas le parcmètre on
est bien d'accord ne les voyez il est
évident que la loi une dimension valeur
absolue pour tous dans l'espace du vivre
ensemble et que personne fût ce au titre
de sa religion ne peut commencer à s'y
soustraire on est bien d'accord mais
pour autant en faire une sorte
d'instance suprême qui viendraient jusqu
à gouverner l'espace des consciences
c'est entrer dans un système qui n'a pas
dû philosophie qui devient totalitaire
donc ben en fait je crois qu'on est
assez vite d'accord sur ce sujet donc il
ya des emballements sur la base de
formule malheureuse il faut qu'on en
sorte d'abord dans l'intérêt des
victimes parce que faut pas qu'on perde
de vue que c'est ça qu'il faut qu'on
mette au centre maintenant alors
juridiquement quand même parce que c'est
intéressant d'avoir votre point de vue
si c'est vrai que quelqu'un qui a conçu
connaissance de d'atteinte sexuelle des
enfants et condamné pénalement ça peut
aller jusqu'à cinq ans de prison et
c'est
bon c'est bien valence a dit un article
qui reconnaît le le droit
le secret professionnel pour pour les
prêtres qu'est ce qui est plus fort
puisqu'on parle de force l'avant
peut-être qu'on verra surtout votre fort
qui peut être choquant bay parce que est
ce que c'est un rapport de force il faut
établir entre entre la religion
justement il est à mai mais sur ce plan
juridique il ya une réponse la réponse
elle et elle est assez clair comme
disait mon seigneur va longtemps
effectivement le secret professionnel
est protégé et une personne qui
dévoilerait une information qui est
protégé par le secret professionnel
eh bien elle peut être poursuivie
sanctionnée par une règle pénale sertic
226-13 du code pénal qui prévoit ça mais
on a un article juste derrière le 200
26-14 qui prévoit une exemption à 7 à
ces sanctions lorsque l'information
concerne des actes de paix de
criminalité donc c'est à dire qu'on peut
révéler une information qui relèvent du
secret professionnel si il y à un des
questions de pédocriminalité derrière et
on considère même dans le code pénal et
c'est que il ya aussi une obligation de
révéler ces informations là une personne
qui ne révèlerai pas qu'ils auraient
connaissance des informations et qu'il
l'ait révèlerai pas pour elle-même être
sanctionné et celle concerne aussi des
avocats lors
bas ça c'est tout le débat parce que là
nous on se fait rogner petit à petit
notre spécial c'est une vraie question
le problème
c'est une vraie question puisque dans
une société où la transparence et de
plus là on n'est pas ce qui nous
concerne quand bien même on ne participe
pas à l'acte délictueux par exemple sur
problématique de fraude fiscale ou
d'optimisation fiscale et sur le
problème du blanchiment on peut avoir
des perquisitions et des veuves prendre
des pièces du dossier que ce soit même
des courriers confidentiels des
consultations confidentiel donc on peut
avoir une
une atteinte au secret professionnel qui
est extrêmement important et ça je
trouve que c'est très grave la
conférence nationale des bâtonniers
monté au créneau avec une notion de
motion de censure
maintenant la loi était votée en
première lecture le sénat c'est au sénat
pour le moment et c'est vrai que nous on
est très choquée de cette infraction et
de ceux de cet empiètement tout cas sur
notre ce que la profession maintenant de
toute façon générale quand on voit si on
va sur la pédocriminalité
quand on voit la personne en général a
été arrêté donc comprendre la rive on
arrive après coup nous regarde pas
quelqu'un qui va venir me voir le
cabinet en ne disant pas équipés je suis
en train de
voir si quelqu'un a dit gilles j'ai
commis des crimes pédophiles voilà
est-ce que c'est ce qu' il faut vous
alliez le dénoncer ou est ce que vous
m'avez parlé ou kwakwa cas très précis
nous il ya une personne qui était
poursuivi pour coups et blessures
volontaires et dans le dossier en fait
elle a avoué à l'avocat qu'en réalité
donc elle avait poussé quelqu'un dans
les escaliers pour des motifs je vais
pas revenir dessus donc imposé pousser
la personne dans les escaliers qui était
totalement inanimé en bas et elle a
étouffés parce qu'elle ne voulait pas
plus de personnes parlent elle l'a
étouffé et à la mise dans une poubelle
et dans le cadre du dossier il était
possible de dire parce que l'étouffement
était pas approuvées dont médicalement
dans le dossier il était possible de
dire que ce n'était que des coups et
blessures volontaires mais elle a avoué
la totalité à son avocat qui l'a
renvoyée en fait à sa propre conscience
parce que c'est pas voilà c'est
maintenant vous y réfléchissez c'était
avant l'été vous y réfléchissez pendant
l'été de savoir si vous vous dénoncez où
vous vous dénoncez pas moi je peut
plaider le dossier sur cette façon là
mais c'est mc pas à l'avocat d'aller
dire oui en fait elle l'a tuée mais je
la dois pas le rôle de l'avancé bien que
le secret professionnel donc laissé
alors je lisais ce que disait un prêtre
parce que c'est vrai qu'on a tendance à
faire des débats théoriques et y
seraient pour le dispose peut-être pas
et qu'ils aient b et est ce que c'est ce
que disent les spécialistes un pédophile
va jamais veut dire confessio pour dire
j'ai cru j'ai commis des crimes peu der
wiel ça n'existe pas dans la réalité
c'est pour ça que moi aussi je dirai ce
que vous avez dit à savoir que la
quasi-totalité des pédophiles que nous
rencontrons nous prêtres on les
rencontre en prison c'est les aumôniers
de prison qui sont plus au contact de
pédophilie parce que les psychiatres le
disent tous il s'agit de personnes qui
sont dans une logique de justification
de leurs actes en gros leur discours a
eu c'est que c'est la faute de l'enfant
est donc bien sûr que c'est tout à fait
antinomique avec le fait de venir ce
qu'on faisait d'ailleurs d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça que la commission sauvé ne
posent pas la question en ces termes là
parce qu'elle sait que ce n'est pas ça
la réalité à laquelle on est confronté
oui la réalité c'est sans doute de et
alors ça probablement que qu'il y avait
eu des comportements qui était connue au
sein de l'église et qui n'ont pas été
traités
sur la je la réalise et créer de la
confession la réalité que pointe la
commission sauvé je pense qu'il faut
qu'on travaille avec beaucoup de sérieux
c'est de dire en fait c'est la question
des confidences incidente tenir dans le
cas de la confession un enfant qui vient
dire qu'il est victime donc là on n'est
pas dans un pédophile qui se confesse un
enfant nous sommes à dire quelle ville
qu'est ce qu'on fait ce qu'on veut c'est
ça la question de la commission sauvé
utilisons très sérieuse très très qu'il
faut qu'on travaille sérieusement parce
qu'évidemment le secret de la confession
ne peut pas être invoquée au détriment
des victimes c'est évident que c'est
mais c'est quelque chose moi que je
déplore un peu depuis depuis une semaine
c'est qu'on voit bien que ce rapport n'a
pas encore été vraiment ouvert pas
encore vraiment été lu
des
textes à ce que chacun se servent un peu
comme un élément qu'on ne veut pas y
aller mais qui canent l'armoire de nos
préjugés et c'est pour ça qu'on va
avancer quoi là il ya une autre question
aux pays bas prévoient passer d'autres
d'autres sujets mais
certains dinosaures on a vu des articles
du d'ailleurs dans les journaux il ya
une solution très simple pour en finir
avec ces actes c'est le mariage des
prêtres alors autre exemple typique si
vous voulez d'un débat qui est né sans
même avoir lu la cnsa page de couverture
du rapport
en fait le rapport sauver lui-même dit
l' inverse mais moi j'ai trouvé qu'une
des grandes richesses de ce rapport
c'est l'infini cette question qui relève
du lieu commun on est tous d'accord là
dessus 1 et qui dit d'abord un 6 90% des
crimes sexuels en france sur des enfants
sont commis dans le cadre des amis et de
la famille c'est bien la preuve que la
question avec le célibat est un il est
différent et heureusement parce qu'il
faut quand même rappeler que la vie
célibataire c'est le statut de 50% des
habitants de paris aujourd'hui donc s'il
y avait s'il y avait un lien de cause à
effet on serait vraiment dans les
nations catastrophique bon et par contre
par contre la commission sauvé ne se
contente pas de botter en touche elle
pose les questions qui qui qui sont
effectivement lié au célibat équilibre
psychoaffectif
de l'ailé les accompagnements delà de
l'aptitude au choix comment on fait que
ce show comment on fait pour que dans la
durée ce choix de vie ne conduisent pas
purement et simplement à une misère
affective donc c'est à la fois
l'accompagnement la formation et l'image
qu'on projette de la personne
célibataire pour qu'elle soit pas mise
sur un piédestal comme un être sacré que
pose la sias et là encore c'est des
vrais belle question qu'il faut qu'on
travaille voyez sans tomber dans la
trivialité une espèce de rapport de
cause à effet qui de l'avis même des
psychiatres puisque plusieurs se sont ré
exprimé depuis une semaine n'existe pas
alors on voit votre livre bâtir ou les
ai trouvés l'église c'est vrai que je
suppose que les catholiques passe
parfois par des moments de doute et
parfois par des bourgs de
volonté c'est de construction il est
possible d'ailleurs que le mariage des
prêtres répondent à une autre question
qui est celle de la vocation parce que
c'est vrai qu'on voit je crois que les
années 50 il y avait
cinquante mille prêtres y en à peu près
quinze mille 15 buts aujourd'hui dont
donc beaucoup de plus de 75 ans brun
c'est vrai que c'est un vrai problème le
teaser de vocation c'est peut-être aussi
dans le choix d'ailleurs des prêtres
eux-mêmes enfin de la sélection n'est
pas trop mal oui c'est sûr
qu'aujourd'hui notre église et les à la
croisée des chemins il n'y a pas de
doute là dessus
on a un peu l'impression si vous l'avez
ce rapport sauvé de devoir de devoir
réaliser une sorte d' opération à coeur
ouvert quoi donc c'est compliqué c'est
douloureux c'est risqué mais on voit
bien que ces genres de risques que si on
ne prend pas on meurt quoi et d'ailleurs
c'est la première fois je crois non il
ya un sondage ifop où il ya une majorité
de français 51 % se disent non croyants
je crois que c'est la première fois dans
l'histoire des marges en tout cas ce qui
m'a ce qui m'a fait plaisir moi
personnellement parce que c'est bien nos
coeurs car
ça m'a confirmé que je suis bien
français parce que moi si vous demandez
si je crois en dieu je vous dirais que
ça dépend des jours moi aussi je passe
par des doutes moi aussi je passe par
des questions et je pense que c'est une
question en fait kessaci fluctuante dans
l'intimé de chacun par rapport à
laquelle on répondait chose un peu
différente d'un jour sur l'autre mais
dans le débat rebondit au laissez tomber
vous êtes plutôt pour rebâtir se pose
j'essaye de noms je fus donc voilà ce
qui m'a beaucoup touché c'est quand même
que
jean marc sauvé il a terminé son
épouvantable présentation par le mode
espérances voilà que vous dites et non
pas de soi et vous n'êtes en réalité la
réalité est parfois d'espérance et moi
je fais pas beaucoup touché parce que
finir à la limite il n'était pas obligé
lui c'est un haut fonctionnaire français
oui qui n'a plus rien à prouver à
personne il n'avait pas besoin de mettre
de la pommade sur les plaies d'ailleurs
il n'a pas du tout fait dans son exposé
et donc je me dis voilà si lui même dit
il ya un espace pour l'espérance mais il
faut qu'on s'en saisissent alors on va
peut-être pas ça une question un peu
plus générale maintenant qui est celle
de la politique de l'église et de la
veille city pif dans un troisième temps
on abordera avec le livre quelques
questions précises sur
sur le droit de comment ce code la
religion dans la société commence ce que
dit le droit mais d'abord peut-être des
questions un peu plus générale sur la
politique église et laïcité
[Musique]
alors on peut rappeler peut-être les
principes constitutionnels qui résistent
laïcité en france c'est dans la
constitution
c'est dans la constitution c'est même à
l'article 1er de la constitution puisque
notre constitution dit que la france est
une république indivisible laïque
démocratique et sociale donc c'est un
article 1er de la constitution et cette
laïcité en fait elle définit de
neutralité de l'état vis-à-vis dès
religions
d'une part c'est à dire que l'état n'est
pas soumis aux religions et ne ne va pas
guider une certaine favoriser une
certaine religion par rapport à une
autre
et puis c'est aussi une définition à la
east delà de la liberté de conscience
c'est à dire que appartement où l'état
n'intervient pas dans les religions que
les religions n'interviennent pas dans
l'état et bien chacun est libre de
croire
sûre de ne pas croire ça c'est je pense
que ce sont des
pays cités vous faut c'est la liberté de
crohn pas quoi on peut le résumer à ça
oui alors après mouche je parle sous
contrôle de rafah le matin dimanche
c'est le fait que finalement la religion
et en dehors du fait public en dehors de
l'espace public c'est ça la laïcité
c'est le fait que comme l'a rappelé je
vais j'ai reprendre ses mots c'est que
la religion n'a pas de contrôle sur
l'état et que l'état n'a pas de contrôle
sur la religion ou sur l'absence de
religion justement c'est ne pas
favoriser l'une ou l'autre et c'est ne
pas empêcher les croyants de pratiquer
leur culte des salaires de laïcité
je reviens je joue nous laisse tomber je
reviens du justement j'ai l'inscription
d'un résident dans la constitution quand
on voit par exemple xavier bertrand dire
il faut montrer de la laïcité dans notre
constitution ben c'est pas sur le même
plan que la liberté ou la fraternité ça
sert à rien il voulait lui la mettre
dans la devise radar était bien égalité
fraternité la liberté
mais
en réalité ça nous aurait peut-être une
portée symbolique mais ça n'aurait pas
de portée juridique particulière parce
que la devise elle est dans la
constitution elle est protégée par le
conseil constitutionnel
le et la laïcité est aussi dans la
constitution est aussi protégé par le
conseil constitutionnel donc c'est
simplement ce que proposait xavier
bertrand de l'affichage ou du symbole
mais pas du tout mais sans aucune
conséquence juridique sur notre capacité
à mieux protéger la laïcité ensuite
derrière à être peut-être plus
intolérant sur l'affichage des religions
ça n'aurait aucune influence
il ya plusieurs périodes enfin dans
l'oeil des rapports historiques en
version entre la laïcité des religions
et l'état il ya eu des tensions en 1905
et bien évidemment il ya une sorte de
grand apaisement
au fond d'après là de la deuxième guerre
jusque jusqu'aux années 80 il est
peut-être la loi savary en 85 qui avait
qui a mobilisé beaucoup les notamment
les jeunes dans l'enseignement
catholique et puis on a l'impression que
cet apaisement aujourd'hui n'est plus là
qu'on est un peu dans un nouveau dans le
dirai pas la guerre mais dans
l'affrontement alors c'est vrai qu'il ya
eu des phases chaudes des phase
d'apaisement la grande phase d'affaires
de d'apaisement il faut pas l'oublier
c'est la guerre de 14 parce que dans la
guerre de 14 les curés comme les
bouffeurs de curés se retrouvent dans
les mêmes tranché et ça a eu un effet
très important sur la cohésion de la
nation à la sortir au sortir de la
guerre bon ben on empêche qu
effectivement ça reste une passion
française qui d'ailleurs n'est pas
complètement compréhensible dans son
côté éruptif par nos voisins étrangers
il ya quinze jours on a passé deux
heures et demie avec le pape les évêques
d'île de france on était en visite à
rome on a passé deux heures et demie
avec lui on a beaucoup discuté et il
nous a pas caché que ce côté éruptif de
la laïcité française il a du mal à le
comprendre
quand même temps sans poignée sur le
sujet bon au delà de tel ou tel
événement
historique enfin celui qui a été le
grand artisan de l'apaisement du débat
c'est le conseil d'état le conseil
d'état maintient avec beaucoup de
sagesse une
interprétation de la laïcité qui est
vraiment dans la ligne de celle
d'aristide briand en 1905 et il l'a
encore fait à l'occasion des confinement
sur la question des recours que nous
avions introduit à propos des quotas
dans les églises et tout ça et ne nous a
pas toujours donné satisfaction quant à
nos recours mais il a redit en quoi
consistait la laïcité dans le sens de ce
qui a été dit et le conseil d'état moi
je souhaite que ça puisse continuer est
vraiment l'artisan par sa jurisprudence
d'une laïcité sage et à laquelle nous
aujourd'hui évidemment on est très
attaché enfin je veux dire objectivement
dans le principe juridique telle que
vous l'avez formulée vous trouverez pas
un évêque catholique par un prêtre
catholique pour se dire en désaccord
avec cette vision des choses enfin le
matin du vidéo est d'accord avec cette
analyse sur le conseil d'état près
d'audruicq ça me fait ça me fait sourire
parce que c'est la preuve que finalement
le conseil d'état la juridiction
illustratif servent à quelque chose
parce que le dans les débats juridiques
notamment entre il ya une guerre entre
les privatiser les publicistes quand je
rentre pas dans le débat mais souvent le
conseil d'état est considérée comme
étant la la botte du gouvernement et
comme étant une juridiction favorables
au gouvernement l exécutif et on voit
régulièrement que finalement le conseil
d'état sait faire la part des choses et
arrive justement vous avez d'une laïcité
sajo gérer aussi une laïcité ouverte
adaptable modulable finalement en
fonction des intérêts en fonction de la
situation le conseil d'état au juge
administratif de manière générale est
capable de faire la part des choses et
de savoir quand est-ce qu'il doit y
avoir une laïcité je dirais stricte et
quand on peut moduler c'est-à-dire
adapter les situations aux circonstances
de l'espèce comme on dit donc
effectivement le conseil d'état et
arrive à réguler et permet de réguler
les choses il nous sauve tout à fait
d'accord avec ce que ce que vient de
dire maintenant valentin et et raphaël
mata duvignau sur l'exemple des crèches
de noël règne dans les mairies
l'article 28 de la loi 1905 sur glace
tramelan et y aller il ya des voilà des
mères qui veulent faire des crèches et
certains disent mais non c'est un
endroit public donc et on va faire de
signes religieux dans cette république
qu'est la mairie ainsi si on vous lit la
loi 1905 sur la séparation de l'église
et de l'état interdiction de mettre des
symboles religieux surtout monuments ou
espace emplacements publics interdiction
conseil d'état a dit que pour les
crèches il pouvait y avoir une
autorisation d'émettre si elles n'ont
pas de signification religieuse
particulière donc c'est une sorte comme
le disait qu'on me dit raphaël ou comme
dit monseigneur à l'antenne de laïcité
apaisée hâtivement rappelez vous appelez
conciliante qui permet de concilier à la
fois tradition mais aussi
mais aussi bien nécessaire séparation on
part donc oui je me permets d'intervenir
parce qu'il ya une jurisprudence
justement du conseil d'état alors là
j'ai perdu la date mais très récente
dans laquelle il ya eu un recours pour
laquelle il ya eu un recours c'était une
ville qui a choisi d emblème religieux
pour pour le blason de la ville d'oka eu
un recours et le conseil d'état a
considéré que les éléments religieux qui
figurait dans le blason était plutôt
relatifs à l'histoire de la ville de la
culture de la ville est donc finalement
ça ne portait pas atteinte à la laïcité
et que cette villa pouvait très bien
arborer un signe religieux dans son
blason enfin là c'est justement ce
mouvement voit la cia des eaux folle
elle rééditer leurs forces sur le sol
idéologie et mais justement on avait
parlé avec vous au moment de la loi sur
le séparatisme il ya eu une attitude
quand même d'aider de l'église peut-être
parce que on la mettait ce même pire que
d'autres d'autres religions qu'on
voulait peut-être
n'ont pas attaqué mais enfin mettre au
pas sans le dire notre inquiétude elle
et elle était de l'ordre de la
philosophie du droit en fait si on
résume les choses c'est à dire que notre
la lecture que nous continuons à faire
de cette loi c'est qu'elle
tire la laïcité vers un esprit néo
concordataire voilà c'est à dire que on
n'est plus tout à fait dans ce qui a été
dit précédemment
alors le boycott d'un régime qui était
avant 1905 et dans lequel les évêques et
les prêtres étaient des fonctionnaires
du ministère de l'intérieur c'est un
boulot voilà c'est napoléon avec le papy
set et ça a organisé le la question
religieuse en croire pendant un siècle
donc c'est quand même une réalité
juridique qui subsistent encore
aujourd'hui en alsace et en moselle bon
donc le régime était en fait voilà les
ministres des cultes sont des
fonctionnaires du ministère de
l'intérieur et donc
les évêques avaient fait une homélie
qu'avec des plus était convoqué au
ministère de l'intérieur parce qu'ils
étaient fonctionnels à l'intérieur
d'accord donc quand on voit ces
dernières heures la fp titre et que eric
de moulins beaufort et chroniques
mais en fait on de
la mode la 2de de la pirouette voyez il
ya dans la dans les dernières
dispositions qui ont été prises on avait
parlé ensemble ici des éléments qui
reviennent dans ce sens là alors c'est
qu'on passe pas du tout au rien mais
demandé au diocèse tous les cinq ans
désormais de revenir le préfet pour
obtenir un agrément pour continuer à
fonctionner comme diocèse puisque sa
désormais c'est dans la loi ça nous
semble si vous voulez une sorte de deux
d'inflexion aux romains de la laïcité
qui est qui n'est pas justifié alors on
est en train de discuter on nous dit non
mais vous inquiétez pas ça sera par un
simple courrier n'empêche n'empêche que
qu'est ce qui fonde en laïcité
le fait qu'ils aient un diocèse
doivent tous les cinq ans se représenter
devant le préfet pour lui dire est ce
que vous appelez nous maintenons nos
statuts juridiques c'est une question
oui qui n'est pas de l'ordre de
l'amour-propre froissé ou du fait qu'on
devrait traiter différemment des autres
et c'est juste on dit voilà la laïcité
c'est un cadre clair qui a été
reformulée il faut s'y tenir je voulais
commenter ce juste faudrait peut-être
pour préciser alors sauf erreur de ma
part mais les associations diocésaines
bénéficient de certaines allant parle
par le biais de l'agrément bénéficient
de certaines dispositions notamment
fiscales par exemple je prends je prends
juste donc obtenir ça c'est le point de
vue du juriste
demandez en tout cas à retourner devant
l'administration quelques tous les cinq
ans tous les quatre ans pour obtenir de
nouveaux l'agrément je n'y vois rien de
choquant parce que par exemple les
associations sportives je fais juste un
parallèle les fédération française de
sport elles sont où tous les quatre ans
elle repasse devant le ministère des
sports pour obtenir l'agrément et
notamment pour obtenir ce qu'on appelle
la délégation de service public donc
d'une certaine manière et ça beaucoup
d'associations le font donc puisque les
diocèses sont des associations je ne
vois pas en couple mise à part je
comprends votre point de vue ans il y
avait aucun problème mais sur le plan
juridique je ne vois pas quelle est la
qu elle serait l'obstacle qu'une
association qui bénéficie d'un certain
nombre d'agréments d'autorisation
initiative puisse retourner devant
l'autorité administrative pour obtenir
c'est justement ces autorisations ces
agréments il n'y a pas de je pense pas
qu'il y ait d'atteinte aux à la laïcité
ou d'atteinte à la liberté d'exercer le
culte
windows inflexion 800 signatures et un
peu les choses mais je pourrais donner
s'ils voulaient d'autres exemples cette
loi donne aussi des pouvoirs de police
sur le contenu des prêches qui là encore
interrogé évidemment on est tous
d'accord sur les questions de sécurité
publique sur les questions de cohésion
nationale mais est ce que c'était
vraiment le bon moyen que de mettre en
place
pour dire la même chose avec un autre
vocabulaire une espèce de laïcité du
soupçon moi je suis je pense que non je
pense que c'est contreproductif
la question c'est est-ce que ça ne
concerne pas que les associations qui a
une délégation de service public ce que
vous disiez où il fallait tous les
quatre ans non parce que n'a pas que
dans l'agrément est d'accord l'agrément
est précaire
pour toute l'association dû bénéficier
d'un agrément dans les régimes
spécifiques
peut-être avant de passer aux questions
très concrètes qui sont abordés dans les
airs une question plus philosophique toi
c'est marcel gaucher qui dit plus une
société se sécularise s'éloigne un peu
de la religion plus elle a besoin de la
religion ne serait-ce que ne serait ce
que pour permettre de penser des limites
de la laïcité
moi ma conviction dont anthropologique
ceclad gestion spirituel on la porte
tous en soit voilà après chacun y répond
de la manière qui lui semble juste
certains vont s'inscrire dans telle ou
telle religion d'autres vont développer
des ddd des réponses spirituelle plus
individuel plus personnel plus on
pourrait dire hors cadre mais ce qui est
clair c'est qu'on évacuera jamais la
question spirituelle parce qu'elle fait
partie du simple fait d'être homme
d'être femme et donc effectivement la
question spirituelle et sera toujours au
coeur de nos débats pour une grand
semble qu'on veuille ou non mais du coup
il ya quand même grande fracture entre
l'église et les grandes fractures une
fracture pour certains entre
l'institution de l'église et les
pratiquants parce qu'on voit qu'il ya de
moins en moins de pratiquants ce qui
peut peut-être expliquer qui est
peut-être moins en moins de prêtres mais
il ya eu une fracture qui fait que les
gens désertent mais se créer des
communautés justement lié à leur foi qui
peut être en dehors dehors de l'église
donc il ya aussi j'imagine que vous
réfléchissez bien évidemment sur ce
sujet là mais une fracture qui est
intervenu au fil au fil des années entre
les années 50 et aujourd'hui où on voit
toutes les études et des statistiques
qui démontrent que il ya de moins en
moins de pratiquants oui c'est sûr que
dans une société dans une culture de
plus en plus fluide les gens
s'inscrivent de moins en moins dans
quelques institutions que ce soit
regarder l'état des partis politiques
aujourd'hui siens à six mois des
élections présidentielles s'applique pas
une bonne nouvelle mais dans ce contexte
de fluidité des engagements et des
appartenances il est évident qu'une
église qui se penserait comme une sorte
de casernes a pas en régie menthe et
tous ses fidèles n'a plus d'avenir il
est clair qu'il faut qu'on pense nous
mêmes cette fluidité cette fuite et
d'appartenance de conviction et de de
lien de rattachement vous avez tout à
fait raison
oui je pense sur la laïcité à mon sens
c'est une sorte de baromètre aussi qui
nous permet de mesurer quel est notre
degré de tolérance et de la religion et
quel est l'écart que l'on met entre
l'état et la religion or moins il y a
deux personnages mesrine pas en tant que
juriste mais peut-être juste en tant que
citoyen mais
- il y a deux religions dans l'état moi
on est capable de mesurer cette distance
entre l'état et la religion et par
conséquent plus on oublie en fait de
préserver cette distance-là et et de
l'expliquer et c'est ce qui provoque
peut-être des incompréhensions de la
part de certains
qui vont par exemple je pense à aux
protestations qui peut y avoir contre
les caricatures de mahomet dans charlie
hebdo ou alors les protestations contre
je me souviens en 2011 la pièce de
théâtre de romeo castellucci au théâtre
de la ville etc la plupart départ décalé
les plus fondamentalistes mais mais
c'est peut-être que moins il ya de
religieux en france - on peut prendre le
pouls et la température en fait de quel
est le rapport entre l'état et la
religion monsieur b c est ce qu un peu
ce que dit un
peu sa tête là l'église est toujours là
la fille aînée enfin la france est
toujours la fille aînée de l'église
le on a posé la question au pape il ya
quinze jours il nous a dit oui mais pas
la plus facile à manier
l'humour oui il a l'humour et il aime la
france parce que voyez la dernière
question qu'on lui impose essai de votre
point de vue de la france la france vont
ensemble qu'est-ce qui est le plus beau
en france d'après vous et il nous a dit
que jacques au tac la créativité la
créativité humaine vous êtes un peuple
capable de faire du neuf d'inventer de
vous réinventer la principale beauté de
la france nous aide c'est la créativité
c'est votre livre reconstruire
en quelques ça arrive est divisée j'ai
été touchée de ce regard très post qui
porte notre pays alors même que nous
même on peut avoir tendance la fed mais
à la noirceur c'est l'aimant alors voilà
la troisième partie de cette émission là
là ici dans nos pratiques on va on va
poser un certain nombre de questions
c'est comme tout le monde se pose et
vous allez nous dire c'est juridiquement
quel est l'état du droit la laïcité
[Musique]
alors par exemple d'une question oui qui
se console le port du voile et
est-ce qu'on peut licencier une femme
qui porte un voile par exemple
vient peut-être la vanille
et dans une différence entre le public
et le privé alors oui bien sûr il ya une
différence entre le public et le privé
mais le principe alors dans le public
c'est interdit strictement puisque là on
est dans la laïcité pure et dure dans le
privé le principe c'est qu'on ne peut
pas venir dans une entreprise avec un
signe ostentatoire religieux par exemple
quelqu'un qui viendrait avec une croix
comme la vôtre loool en valeur les
ballerines ployart pourrait demander à
ce qu'elle soit retirée
s'agissant du voile il n'ya plusieurs
principes qui ont été posées par la
jurisprudence que ce soit la cour
européenne de justice et la cour de
cassation qui suit les principes de
poser par la cour européenne de justice
c'est que 1 il faut que ce soit un
principe de proportionnalité c'est à
dire que l'interdiction du port du voile
correspondent à une à une légitime
volonté de l'entreprise peut-être
d'imposer cette laïcité notamment par
exemple en interdisant une personne
porte une voile lorsqu'elle va en
clientèle lorsqu'elle est à l'extérieur
en contact avec des clients avec des
commerciaux
donc tout ça c'est le premier principe
mais le principe qui est au dessus c'est
qu'il faut que ce soit prévu dans le
règlement intérieur de l'entreprise
c'est ce qu'a rappelé la cour européenne
de justice il y avait deux décident y
avait deux décisions de cour d'appel à
la fois en france et en belgique sur des
sujets exactement similaires si ce n'est
qu'en belgique y avait un règlement
intérieur qui prévoyait les conditions
où on pouvait interdire tout signe
ostentatoire religieux et notamment le
voile c'était prévu dans le règlement
intérieur et ça a été donc imposé à une
personne qui était en contact avec de la
clientèle de retirer son voile
là la cour européenne de justice a dit
c'est valable en france c'était
exactement le même cas de figure si
c'était qui avait pas de règlement
intérieur dans l'entreprise et ce à un
règlement intérieur pour l interdire le
règlement intérieur peut l'interdît mais
pas aussi et cache donc il faut que ce
soit général comme interdiction que ce
soit proportionné et la loi elle
conneries à donner le mode d'emploi je
veux dire elle a exactement défini ce
qui devait être dans le règlement
intérieur à la limite il suffit de faire
un copier coller du paragraphe qui est
dans la loi une connerie pour le mettre
dans le règlement intérieur et ensuite
c'est pas n'importe quelle entreprise
une entreprise où il n'y a pas de
contact avec la clientèle on peut pas
interdire le port du voile à l'intérieur
de l'entreprise après il ya un principe
aussi de santé sécurité c'est à dire que
quand bien même on est toujours dans le
sein de l'entreprise si quelqu'un un
voile qui travaillent une jeune femme
qui travaille sur une machine qui
pourrait embarquer son voile là on peut
lui interdire il y avait du mal car de
douala de sécurité il y avait un cas
d'un indic y avait un turban et qui
refusait de le retirer alors qu'il
devait mettre un casque de chantier là
il ya quand même un problème donc on est
la frite c'est difficile facile voilà
c'est pas facile donc il faut bien avoir
c3 c3 problématique et puis après il ya
des problématiques comportementaux dans
l'entreprise avec des salariés qui
refusent de s'asseoir sur ce matin juste
pour compléter ce qui vient d'être dit
il ya eu aussi la jurisprudence ou des
personnes des hommes barbus refusait de
raser leurs barbes parce qu'ils devaient
mettre justement pour des raisons
religieuses mais on leur imposait pour
des raisons de sécurité pour porter le
masque ou un casque et donc c'est pareil
les personnes ont été licenciées c'était
licenciement était de valider
l'injustice oui mais là vous avez deux
décisions de 2021 avec des deux bars
c'est vraiment les licenciements étaient
déclarés sans cause réelle et sérieuse
parce qu'il n'y avait pas de problème de
sécurité parce que il n'y avait pas
et puis et puis même
procédé est ce qu'il ya des chais
des croyants et des catholiques pardon
est ce qu'il ya des questions qui vous
reviennent sur le la manifestation de
ces conditions de sa croyance dans une
entreprise où est ce que n'ont pas
vraiment parce que sur ces questions de
prescription je dirais visible
prescriptions vestimentaires
prescriptions alimentaires la tradition
catholique et surimi assez différentes
objectivement il faut aussi c'est une
des exigences de la laïcité qu'elle a
parfois un peu de mal à honorer faut
aussi être capable d'appréhender les
questions spécifiques que pose chaque
religion voyez ce que les religions
n'ont pas toutes le même rapport à la
vie commune le même rapport à l'état le
bon sur ces questions objectivement
vestimentaire de signes ostensibles les
questions alimentaires
objectivement on sent pas très concernés
non c'est vrai qu'il est donc je me suis
alors c'était pendant les en 2017 la
botte des élections présidentielles il y
avait une porte parole de françois
fillon qui viennent y croit être mon
celi mais pourquoi elle porte une fois
son
nom me semble-t-il au feu puis il a même
sens y avait une candidate la république
en marche récemment qui sur une affiche
porter un voile l'équipe de campagne l'a
exclu de la fiche et là certains ont dit
c'est discriminatoire est là pour le
coup non l'équipe de campagne elle dort
partis politiques fait ce qu'il veut la
laïcité s'applique pas ces gens vient
vous voir il ya eu la sphère babilou fin
de da de la crèche de chanteloup les
vignes
là on était alors on n'est pas dans le
public mais dans une concession de
service public je suppose
oui c'est ça privé
et il ya eu interdiction mais c'était
justement ce qui a donné lieu ensuite à
la loi comme rim a vécu à toute
l'algérie cependant ce que c'était
florence les décisions de justice c'est
à dire est-ce qu'on peut licencier une
personne qui portent pas parce que elle
refuse d'enlever des signes religieux et
là il ya eu pas mal de divergences entre
les juges etc et donc il a fallu la loi
elle comrie puis il des décisions de la
cour de justice de l'union européenne
qui ont dit comme le dit et florence à
l'heure une entreprise peut interdire de
porter des signes religieux si c'est
justifié pour des raisons de sécurité
droit le seul hic le public et que c'est
prévu par le règlement intérieur
appartement on a ces deux conditions on
peut très bien interdire de porter des
signes religieux et licenciés s'ils
refusent de les retirer
j'avais justement à la loi comme ris
parce qu'il y avait beaucoup de 2,2
rumeurs justement sur cette voie et ça a
été repris par par certains des
créations politique on disait qu'elle
interdisait aux chefs d'entreprises de
limiter des manifestations des
convictions et des pratiques religieuses
d'essayer
non parce qu'on l'a beaucoup entendu sa
fille marine le pen notamment a beaucoup
diffusé cette information là c'est
totalement le contraire pour une avocate
en plus un de formation c'est quand même
la problématique de dire ça à une
déclaration fausse après
les manifestations des signes religieux
à l'école par exemple ça vous pose un
problème humain mouvement manifestation
non encore une fois vous savez sur ces
questions nous on est guidé par une
phrase du christ dans l'évangile qui dit
c'est à l'amour que vous aurez les uns
pour les autres qu'on vous reconnaîtra
comme mes disciples bon donc nous en
fait on est guidé par un texte et
malheureusement on est loin de le mettre
en oeuvre qui nous dit que notre signe
ostensible ça doit être l'amour qu'on a
pour les autres à partir de là vous
comprenez bien que des grisons de
vêtements de croix comporte comporte pas
de signe qu'on met ou qu'on met pas nous
apparaissent secondes franchement
secondes ils nous ont beaucoup plus
important c'est ce qui est de l'or du
respect des consciences et de
l'apprentissage au vivre ensemble
lorient et des bas c'est à dire comment
faire de l'école publique et de nos
écoles catholiques tout autant des lieux
d'apprentissage du vivre ensemble
comment est-ce qu'on introduit les
jeunes dans un rapport intelligente à la
religion de l'autre là pour nous nous
sommes la vraie question qui n'est pas
du tout de leur de savoir si la médaille
de baptême elle doit être portée sur le
plus douces ou d'un autre ordre mon avis
qu'est ce qui fait d'ailleurs que des
religions en plus besoin de signes
ostentatoires que d'autres j'ai passé
lors du besoin je pense que c'est de
l'art de la tradition ne va essayer
c'est la tradition culturelle parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de culture et l d'air
tout ça les musulmans eux-mêmes
débattent pour savoir si le voile et
religieux ou s'il ne l'est pas si les
papilles d'agréer monsieur
il ya beaucoup de culturel der sar il ya
beaucoup de cultuelle absolument et
d'interprétation justement ont eu un
grand débat sur les les mères de
familles qui accompagnent les enfants
dans les sorties scolaires
non elles peuvent pas porter de signes
ostentatoires notamment de woillemont
alors le débat et existe le débat n'est
toujours pas tranchée il ya plusieurs
questions qui se posent la première
c'est
comment qualifie ton les parents en fait
quelle est la qualité juridique des
parents est ce qu'on peut leur appliquer
la laïcité ou pas alors il faut repartir
sur la loi de 2004 qui interdit aux
enfants aux usagers du service public de
l'éducation de porter les sinistrés
manquent ostensible et quid quid des
parents alors il faut savoir aussi
que font les parents si les parents
accompagnent les enfants en sortie
scolaire ils sont considérés maintenant
je fais et à la jurisprudence actuelle
ils sont considérés alors sept morts ça
c'est sur ce débat ils sont considérés
comme étant des usages et indirects du
service du service de l'éducation
nationale et donc par conséquent les
parents peuvent les maires peuvent
porter le voile à condition là c'est la
base ensuite le chef d'établissement
peut leur demander à ces mères pour des
raisons liées à l'ordre public à la
tranquillité pour preuve leur peuvent
leur demander lors qu'il ya de retirer
elles le font ou ne font pas non après
il peut pas et ne peut pas leur imposer
d'atteindre leur demander mais pas
laurent bellet ainsi le refus causerait
un trouble à l'ordre public dans ce cas
là le chef d'établissement serait en
droit de leur interdire la sortie saint
aulaire vous voyez tout le tout
l'enchaînement après aussi principe de
réalité dans certains établissements on
peut pas faire autrement le chef
d'établissement doit faire avec ça c'est
un premier point un autre point c'est
quid des mères qui viennent assister à
une réunion parents-profs à l'école là
elles ne sont plus comme tous considérés
comme des usagers du service public
elles sont considérées comme simplement
les parents des enfants et donc là elles
peuvent venir pour revenir vous allez y
avait aucun problème il y avait autre
chose et que j'ai oublié c'est qu'est-ce
que la question puisque le soulève la
question juridique on si c'était de les
considérer c'est ce qu'avaient dit les
meilleurs mc ren ai dit ce sont des
collaboratrices occasionner de service
public donc elles sont soumises à la
laïcité alors l'école pour l'instant la
jurisprudence a refusé de les qualifier
de collaborateurs occasionnels du
service public parce que bon ça
entraînerait d'autres d'autres questions
juridiques notamment sur la question de
la responsabilité si jamais elle a fait
un accident par exemple au cours d'un
trajet ils vous aviez relevé dans votre
livre assure une femme voilée qui avait
participé à une réunion
à la mairie du conseil municipal et où
il y avait eu tout un esclandre sûr sur
cette problématique là et en fait elle
pouvait la gale pouvait garder son voile
oui parce qu'elle était la dame
citoyenne c'est pas parce qu'elle était
à l'intérieur du numérique exactement
usagers des services publics peut aller
dans les services publics avec ces
signes religieux et on ne parlera pas
lui demander de les retirer de ce sont
les agents des agents sur qui doivent
le tout à l'heure vous aborder la
question de céleri qui veulent peuvent
serrer la main des femmes par exemple
oui elle à niamey il ya eu plusieurs
plusieurs cas
salariés qui viennent pas des voix des
salariés qui viennent serre la main des
hommes et refuse de serrer la main des
femmes où il y avait eu un cas aussi
d'un salarié qui a refusé de monter dans
un bus parce que le trajet damman avait
été fait par une femme il voulait pas
s'asseoir sur un fauteuil ou avait été
assise une femme donc là on est sûr
aussi sur autre chose qui est de l'adisq
et de la discrimination hommes femmes ça
c'est le biais dans lequel on peut
rentrer et ne pas se mettre sur la
problématique religieuse donc là il ya
des textes qui sont extrêmement claires
alors je pense qu'il faut avoir un
minimum de pédagogie notamment sur je
refuse de serrer la main et j'avais un
client qui avait eu ce problème là et où
il a demandé aux salariés finalement de
serrer la main à personne
et donc en serrant la main à personne
mais il s'adressait aux femmes vous
pouvez parler avec elle c'était pas de
l'exclusion c'était juste et donc
finalement il a serré la main à personne
aimée est rentré dans l'ordre dont il ya
peut-être aussi des solutions
alternatives plutôt que de rentrer
direct
et de licencier salariés parce que il
fait des ruminations une femme il ya
d'autres moyens que de rentrer aussi
dans
mais dans le religieux après l'autre
problème sont les prières heureusement
ce que vous utilisez vous saisir tout
allait à se dire que là beaucoup on le
voit de ses problèmes
qu'on appelle le problème d'eau de
rapports de religion ou à l'état sont au
fond des problèmes plus culturel que
religieux oui même là pour le dernier
exemple vous a donné des problèmes
éducatifs et des qualifs
c'est vrai que c'est vrai mais on met
sur le dos de la religion des choses et
aux discriminations les peurs les uns
vis-à-vis des autres c'est même pas
d'ordre culturel c'est de l'or éducatif
station bien sûr et comme il l employeur
l'a vu quand même plusieurs fois en dix
ans mais en essayant de dire que c'est
un problème effectivement éducatif et
qu'il faut qu'ils serrent les mains des
femmes et là ils étaient but et il y en
était hors de question donc ça c'est
résolus autrement parce que c'est un bon
élément il travaillait bien enfin bon il
n'y avait pas de raison de l'exclure de
l'entreprise en dehors de ce problème
éducatif donc ça a été résolu comme ça
et alors l'autre problème sont les
prières en entreprise whisky posent
difficulté parce que les catholiques
peuvent prier sans que ça c'est tout à
fait intérieur sans qu'il y ait de
manifestations extérieures
et des tapes clients étaient sollicités
pour qu'ils aient une salle de prière ou
un endroit pour prier et ça c'est très
très compliquée à mettre en oeuvre parce
que si on dit oui après va y en avoir
d'autres donc croyant qu'ils peuvent
venir réclamer également une salle pour
telle ou telle religion et donc les là
aussi on peut peut-être des solutions
non d'une chapelle le conseil d'état
quand même fois
viser la gagne et l'histoire des yeux
qu'elle aimait française et
pour conclure pardon ce qui ne reste
même pas une minute mais parler d'espoir
après le le rapport sauvé quelques l
espoir que peuvent avoir des des
croyants et des catholiques aujourd'hui
je crois vraiment que la vérité rend
libre parce que c'est un principe qui
est écrit dans l'évangile est donc ce
travail de vérité il est vraiment
douloureux et dur à recevoir parce que
la prod chose qui provoque en nous c'est
de la honte objectivement c'est quand
même le sentiment qui domine depuis une
semaine mais moi je crois qu'il peut il
peut être bien faisons merci infiniment
je rappelle je rappelle le titre de
votre dit
pardon rebâtir ou laisser tomber
l'église au coeur c'est aux éditions
emmanuel et puis les surligneurs voilà
le livre s'appelle roger comme aime le
dire politique religion et laïcité et
cette édition là ça c'est pas facile à
dire jean mary b walryck baissé dans
toutes les bonnes librairies excellent
merci infiniment à peu les cas très très
vite pour un nouveau numéro de pain
[Musique]